recognize this
[Music]
it's been used in hundreds of TV shows
and films it's so famous that if you
can't remember this you can just google
that famous cello song and it will
invariably pop up yes this Prelude is
well-known but perhaps what's most
compelling about it is how incredibly
simple it is the whole thing just takes
up two pages of music and it's composed
for an instrument that has just four
strings yet it's considered a
masterpiece at world-class cellist and
even everyday music listeners have
revered for years so what makes this
composition so memorable timeless and
beautiful well that's what ELISA is
going to help me deconstruct my name is
ELISA Wyler Stein and we are talking
about the prelude from Bach's first
cello suite in G major
[Music]
this is buck and these are his six cello
suites within each suite are various
movements named for dances and they each
have very strict structures these
movements are all masterpieces and music
and they get increasingly complex but
before these dances begin there's always
a prelude in the Box weeks it's a way to
establish the key or you establish some
motives and it's also a kind of
improvisation in this Prelude in
particular is revered because it
achieves a lot with just a few very
simple concepts to understand how you
first have to understand the very basics
of the song there's two main chords and
keys you need to remember here G and D
buck plays them off each other the
entire Prelude G is the home key for
this composition it's called the tonic
minute every tonic has a dominant that's
the note of v above it if this is all
going in one ear and out the next don't
worry just remember this the tonic and
the dominant work really well together
where the dominant represents tension
the tonic represents release and the
cello is the perfect vessel to showcase
this relationship this is a cello it's
the closest in range and an ability to
express to the human voice you start
from the very low range down here so you
can imagine over the bass baritone type
of sound to way up here or this is the
violin range because the prelude is
written in G major it allows for a lot
of open strings on the cello which give
the song a very natural resonance an
open string means that it's I I don't I
don't stomp it with the finger so if I
do nothing with my left hand
the sounds of G with a G major chord two
out of three notes are open this natural
sounding quality is what defines the G
major Prelude and it's exactly what Bach
exploits starting with its first few
measures during the first half of the
composition Bacchus constantly
arpeggiating chords it's a simple
technique that enriches the harmony so
this would be G major chord and then
arpeggiated there's a separation between
between the notes then you go on but he
also does something else
for me one of the most profound aspect
of this is the pedal point which means
that the that the bass note remains
constant even while the harmony is
changing the bass note through the first
four measures is that very natural open
G its job is to keep you rooted in the
key of the song with the bass
[Music]
so then you have that gravitas in there
even while the harmony is moving around
after these four measures though things
start to shift Bach starts to pull the
song away from the tonic to the dominant
[Music]
then we lose the pedal so this is the
first shift right and then here we Lana
D major the dominant
[Music]
a diminished chord here kind of cloud in
the sky a minor then we climb again from
here just like that we're back to that
familiar G pedal point listen for the
bottom G home again
near the end of the first half Bach
again drifts away from g-major and
reaches even deeper into the cellos bass
range with a low C listen to this
the quarters were the with the D here
but then he flips it on his head with a
C on the bottom
[Music]
by the end of the first half Bach has
pulled us completely into D major he's
warming our ears up for the second half
of the composition which is all about
exploring that dominant key in the
beginning of the second half of the
movement right after the Fermata which
means to hold on the note
then you have a very impressive Ori
accession coming up this is actually my
I think my favorite moment of it with
this a flat this dissonance
[Music]
[Music]
and all of that just to get to D major
we know that we have to get back to G
major somehow how are we gonna do it now
we start to kind of climb down
[Music]
see a still in d-major Bach pushes us
more firmly into the world of D major
with a technique called burial OSH it's
when you're making string crossings and
it's actually supposed to kind of create
this kind of feeling of disorder we have
a constant open a string which is this
it's only one note that you're just
repeating over and over again and this
is what causes all this mayhem right all
these attempts to get out of D major and
you can't do it now we're in G major
[Music]
if you didn't catch that something
really quite perfect happened let's play
it again so you just wanted to exactly
where you started here D major and you
have a chromatic scale up
[Music]
and you bettin on this high G here and
that's when we feel this kind of
ecstatic feeling leading up to G majors
big reveal BOC brings back that familiar
petal point from the intro but instead
of using the G as the base note he flips
the chord and uses the dominant D the
base note remains constant even as we're
going up the chromatic scale listen I'll
do it reverse lower
[Music]
okay now I know where I'm going and and
we're so happy about it that we have to
just keep kind of wandering around it
[Music]
and going back to one
[Music]
jealous all over the world wrestled with
this prelude and the cello suites as a
whole every single day we cellists we
always feel sort of unworthy of it the
music is so pure so sublime so emotional
so intellectual
they must be played and yet we feel like
we can't really ever do them justice
[Music]